this is a YouTube only commercial or
advertisement or promo that coca-cola
did sort of explaining how you would
burn off calories by drinking one can of
their delicious soda let's take a look
okay so we actually splice that so you
didn't get the full thing there but the
full thing is on YouTube but basically
they're trying to make it seem like it's
this fun cool thing having to burn off
the calories that it takes 23 minutes of
exercise if you're a hundred forty
pounds for one little 12-ounce can of
coke there's something very perverse
about this is it it relies river that a
certain i live at four pork and it was
it was all people exercising really
working hard like i do all this so that
i can eat pork you know exactly that
except it's really exactly the parody
has now become the real thing and and
that this ad is so well for sold any
open should sue for the slight tweak the
pee-wee's big adventure theme yeah uh
but also the idea that you know yes you
can if you bike for 20 minutes you're at
you're entitled to a coke despite the
fact that a coke has more sugar than the
air than the average adult should
consume an entire day poison yeah i mean
that [ __ ] is the you know and of course
it's high fructose corn syrup we don't
even get the actual sugar you have to go
to Mexico right and even there we are
starting to go high fructose over there
like it but the whole calorie thing
being the end-all be-all is I think
pretty much been establishes kind of a
myth of dining not that I clearly I'm a
weight loss but you know I I think that
that's very much oversimplifying the
thing is though this ad kind of brings
up like I just you know get out work out
and get some slowdown or sugar before we
get to too deep into the cali part out
what I mean doesn't that the idea of
what they're doing here seem really
twist it was I mean the marketing
tactics that these you know junk food
companies you know used to me is
completely pervasive and it drives me
crazy I mean did you guys read that
study that came out last week about how
diet soda you know helps people lose
weight which was actually a study funded
by the American better shot it's crazy
because most studies say that actually
makes you crave sugar and that it you
know of course it converts into benzene
your body and God if I go go to
McDonald's and order a ton of awful food
and then they get a diet soda think
makes never offsetting it yeah yeah
anybody who's interested in this topic
should see my friend Lori David's movie
fed up it's a documentary in theatres
now it's all about this how it's not
just you know a calorie in versus a
calorie out how these you know by
drinking a can of soda it actually
spikes your insulin it prevents you from
feeling satiated you know so it makes
you hungrier
and it's a it's a major player in the
obesity epidemic is cook even
coca-cola's water brand dasani has salt
in it yes it's on the label of salt is
in that [ __ ] so you guys stay thirsty
it's insane ok so then what is coke
doing here what are what are they really
what are the market people saying like
they're just saying we know that people
are more health-conscious so we're gonna
make it seem fun no you know no one's
using this actual machine for exercise I
do cardio not fun and actually it's born
I've been doing it more it's forced me
to cut some of this stuff out of my diet
if they have that rube goldberg thing at
a gym i might consider going to one you
know the videos a big giant hand gonna
give me a coke at the end I might you
know I want that for pee-wee Herman
thing where you do that whole thing just
to get the milk in jerz here absolutely
it was like cocaine rolls down all those
things get in your face when you open
the problem that is a good point i guess
it's on a position cook is like a reward
like there's no better reward for
exercise you know for then a coke coke
right no better award for exercise than
doing something that reverses although
effective it does not quench your thirst
at all after the exertion you've just
gone through a heaven worst atrocities
yeah by the way cut a little more info
on the average soda drinker consumes
about 2.6 glasses each day so this was
two point six cans of coke that would
mean about an hour of cycling so this
stuff is just not good for you and but
when we do all these stories everyone
then attacks me and says you know we
should have our indulgences and that
kind of thing yes I drink some of this
stuff too but we should be more aware of
what's going on here right so sometimes
food as they say on Sesame Street you
know it's a sometimes food you know I if
you have like a coke every couple of
weeks you know it's not going to be the
worst thing in the world for you but yet
2.6 a day that's insane so final thought
should we give coke any credit then for
no no no they're just being purely
Anibal I was just trying to play devil's
poucos just some reason again yeah
dasani is the least offensive product of
the market but even that's tap water and
we're overpaying for it so yeah daddy
consoled in it that's all who doesn't
want salty tap water ok